federal reserve chairman jerome powell
says the fed will start raising interest
rates as soon as march to fight rising
inflation that means everything from car
loans to mortgages could soon be more
expensive inflation worries have sent
stock prices plunging this month here to
break it all down like recycling day cbs
news business analyst jill schlesinger
jill what's going on how are you doing
doing well all right so what what
changes could we see the feds make as
soon as march so it looks like a quarter
point increase coming as soon as march
probably going to see maybe three four
could even be five quarter point
increases jerome powell says this is a
sign the economy is recovering but it's
also a very clear sign inflation's on
the move now what impact would this have
on the consumers well it really impacts
all of us if you are a saver you're
totally psyched because you're saying
hey i'm going to get paid more interest
on my savings my checking my money
market my cds but if you are a borrower
things could start costing more not all
borrowers but if you've got a credit
card balance if you've got maybe a
business loan or a variable home loan
those start those payments will start to
increase as soon as mark what about the
housing market and mortgages the fed
does not control the rate on which
mortgages are based but mortgage rates
have been on the rise anyway in fact we
hit a two-year high in 30 and 15-year
rate mortgages but the thing is this may
be actually a good sign for the housing
market because it's been so hot cooling
it down a little bit isn't so bad it
just makes it hard for a lot of
first-time homebuyers okay so with the
rates expected to rise what can
consumers do pay off any of those
variable loans as quickly as you can
don't deplete all of your emergency
savings but get a jump on this this is
going to be something that's with us
throughout this year and next so pay
down those loans okay with this news
from the fed we have been watching the
stock market um do you expect things to
settle down at all no definitely not no
it's not going to settle down listen i
know what you're going to say stick to
the game plan stick to your game plan
you've got to get you've got to get in
front of this and say i am going to tamp
down my emotions it's going to be
volatile it's not necessarily bad for
stocks so please please don't try to
outguess the fed and do not time that
market when i throw you the ball you
always catch it you're the best in the
business thank you so much jill
schlesinger